[Music]
it's a full speed ahead because this
time of the year is the time when these
decisions are made from a personnel
standpoint speaking of personnel where
are things with blake right now blake is
the quarterback with the jacksonville
jaguars right now
that is hardly a ringing endorsement
from tom coughlin the executive vp of
football operations in jacksonville of
course kept secret in the nfl blake
bortles is about to get whacked by the
jaguars most likely he'll be a post june
1 cut which means that after june 1 his
cap charge will drop for 2019 down to 11
and a half million now 9.3 million next
year they screwed this up last year they
did they know it they had they could
have gone in a bunch of different
directions chris they could have gone
after kirk cousins they could have gone
after teddy bridgewater they could have
gone after tyrod taylor exactly so many
other quarterbacks out there and they
decided to kick the can with blake
bortles and it blew up in their faces
blew up on their face they're in the
worst salary cap situation out of any
team in the nfl right now i mean yeah i
just will never understand what they
were thinking with that contract with
blake bortles i understand he had just
led them to the afc championship game
but certainly they were watching the
same film i was and weren't going wow
we're here because of blake bortles i
mean that was a historic year by their
defense uh it's gonna be interesting to
see where blake bortles ends up and what
jacksonville does at the quarterback
situation are they gonna just draft a
young quarterback and go there are they
going to find a free agent and bring him
into town
nick foles continues to make the most
sense the question is will the eagles
use the franchise tag on him and then
try to trade him or will he hit the open
market but john d filippo is there as
the offensive coordinators got that
history with fall
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports